exactly so yeah so i remember when you
said to me that you wanted to write a
book
and we were talking about it and you
said the the title was going to be an
immigrants a love letter to the west and
that really struck me what what why did
you call it that well first of all in
some ways the title is a bit of a
compromise because i don't know if you
saw the sunday time review which was
broadly positive yes it was one of the
criticisms he made was well what is the
west and actually if it were up to me
and it wasn't just about marketing as
well uh i would have called it an
immigrants love letter to the
anglo-sphere because that's really
the the
countries that i'm talking about i'm not
talking about france yeah right not
least because the french have a very
different conception of
freedom and where it comes from and and
uh you know the the partly the
consequence of the french revolution is
they obsess about reason and rationality
whereas in the anglo-sphere there's also
an appreciation of tradition as as a as
a source of wisdom and a source of
knowledge so it should be called first
of all an immigrant's love letter to the
anglosphere and actually one of the
things that uh i one of the reasons i
wanted to call it that was that it
harkens back to yuri besmanov who you i
showed you some videos of if you
remember yes uh which were very powerful
he was a kgb defector which talked about
the way the soviet union was
demoralizing uh and dividing western
societies particularly the american
society and he wrote a book called a
love letter to america
so i wanted to reference that with the
book and my book is very much making the
point that he was making in his own time
which is
you can mess around with all of the crap
that you and i spend every week
discussing on trigonometry all of this
division and all this cultural bollocks
and all of this sort of in in naval
gazing and obsessing about internal
stuff that doesn't really matter
you can do it as long as you don't have
enemies as long as you don't have people
who are coming as long as you don't have
people who are willing to challenge that
and i've been saying to you and you to
be fair to you you coming from outside
the west somewhat and being uh visiting
uh countries and
outside the west yourself you you know
this
the rest of the world isn't like the
west no
to put it mildly right
and the things that we want isn't
necessarily what people in the west
outside the west want and the methods of
behavior that we have here are not
necessarily the methods of behavior that
people have elsewhere so if we continue
to obsess about things don't matter i
mean it strikes me it's interesting that
the last time you and i were sitting
down like this and talking was the day
after russia invaded ukraine
well these events are not disconnected i
mean i said to someone i can't i think
it was chris williamson interviewed me
for his uh youtube show
and he i i was sort of saying you know
that russia's invasion of ukraine
wouldn't have happened or certainly
wouldn't have happened the way that it
happened or when it happened if it
hadn't been for the culture war and that
sounds like a bold claim and people go
you're a culture warrior blah blah blah
well if you think about it donald trump
failed to get reelected
because of the culture war in some way
right you could there's no question
about that
if trump doesn't get reelected we've had
putin's former advisor andre larry on on
the show saying
by the moment biden got elected this
process started right now this isn't a
partisan point about biden or trump or
whatever my point is
what we do internally in the west
affects how we are seen
elsewhere and it affects the consequence
with the consequences consequences which
we then suffer
which we are essentially inflicting on
ourselves so my point is we've got to
lay all this nonsense to bed and
actually start to focus on very real
problems i'm not just talking about the
threat of russia the the struggle with
china i mean look at what economics is
going to come back to the for you and i
have both talked about this which is why
one of the reasons we we're going to be
getting more and more economists back on
the show interestingly that's how
trigonometry started of course
and that's because there's big problems
and people aren't awake to what's going
to happen
the the rise in fuel prices the rising
food price the food prices what we talk
about is inflation no one really gets
what it's going to be like by the end of
this year
i think people are starting to get it
now what you have i remember when nigel
farage was actually sitting in that very
scene and he said and he actually said
very similar words to use which was i
don't think people understand what's
going to happen
when those bills hit their mats and i
think it was in april or may whenever it
was and he was talking about energy
prices he was indeed add to that fuel
prices and now you've got a global food
crisis going on food prices are going to
go through if you and i just interviewed
only an hour ago peter zahan who talked
about all of this so the economic future
is going to be very challenging for a
lot of people we can't afford to be
banging on about gender fluid lesbians
being oppressed or whatever just you
know i mean and that's kind of why i
wanted to write the book i wanted to
remind people that what we have is great
what we have is valuable we shouldn't
throw it out just because some race
activists want to complain about you
know
air conditioning enough or whatever it
is that they're banging on about we've
got to lay those issues to rest and
we've got to move on and talk about the
serious stuff that actually makes it
different to everyone's life but don't
you think the fact that we're obsessing
of the over these trivial mundane issues
like we went to visit your family in
armenia and i remember sitting down with
them yeah and they went well what are
people talking about in the west and i
said well one of the big issues
actually
uh is uh what is a woman yeah and she
just looked at me like i lost my nuts
what
i i was loving you explaining it because
my whole family were just sitting there
going
what
no
that is not possible what
it is not possible what it is
just because and they were all women as
well right right but but the point is
like none of the [ __ ] is worth talking
about none of it makes sense but we've
got to a position where we're having to
address gcc biology before we can
actually talk about stuff that really
matters and that's a problem francis if
the prime minister of this country is
being asked what a woman is instead of
what his policy is or her policy is on
you know dealing with the cost of living
crisis or the housing crisis or all of
these other real problems
they're naturally going to spend their
time talking about that and less time
thinking and worrying and fixing the
problems that we've actually got i mean
look at the leadership race now you know
you and i for example both quite like
kemi badanok because she's good on
cultural issues right but i don't want
the next prime minister of this country
to be good to to be able to define a
woman i've got higher ambitions
look i completely agree but doesn't
it show that there's something quite
rotten at the core of our society and
the one thing that maybe is is is
perhaps the truth about this is the
reason we've been able to focus so much
on these trivialities is
our lives have been great
now it is my fear and suspicion
that
that may not be
the way that it has been
in the next 10 years i think
we're all going to get a lot poorer
our lives are going to get more
difficult i think the stability and
prosperity we've enjoyed is genuinely
under threat
uh we've seen you know some of the
interviews we've already recorded but
haven't yet put out
you know the end of globalization it has
some benefits of course but in the short
term it's going to be very painful for a
lot of people
um
and perhaps that will be one of the
things that does away with the culture
war somewhat is it forces people to
focus on things that matter
and what are the things that matter well
i think at the moment it's very clear
what matters one is international
security that's been thrown completely
uh in the air by what russia is doing in
ukraine and some of the other moves that
are happening we don't know exactly what
they'll look like and the other thing of
course is economics i mean
people are going to starve around the
world from the famine that's coming uh
we're fortunate in the west to probably
be spared that but you're seeing uh
various things that are happening around
that whether it's in holland whether
it's in sri lanka wherever you want and
the the other thing of course is the
cost of living is going to go up
massively and when that happens
you know we think about it as like oh
well we can't afford as many avocados
over whatever or as many meals out
for a lot of people
it's the the choice between heating and
eating or whatever it is and that's a
genuine fact you know there are a lot of
people pensioners for example in this
country now i know they all voted brexit
so they deserve to die according to some
people but in reality i mean they're
some of the most vulnerable people in
society not least because they're not
able to control their income they can't
go and get a second job or a third job
or whatever to supplement their income
they're going to be in a lot of trouble
and how we deal with that is much more
important to me
than you know dr show low and good
morning britain banging on about how
someone's offended her you know what i
mean no can i look i completely agree
with you and the really interesting
thing about your book is that it
it's doing very it hasn't even been
released yet and it's doing very well on
pre-sales like the reviews have been
great it's already being uh it's already
gone for a reprint it's already had a
reason it's already had a reprint so why
is that well
before i answer that i should say just
how
incredibly grateful i am to and this is
mostly our fans to me yeah i'm very
grateful to you mate
but i i am so grateful that
you know people have the trust that i'm
going to put out there's something worth
reading my first book no reason people
should think that i'd be some great
author but i feel like i've written a
book that's worth reading particularly
given some of the historical context
that i give that people may be
unfamiliar with about my own family the
history of the soviet union i think even
from just if you're interested in
history it's it's it's hopefully a good
book to read
um but to answer your question you know
like you say thousands of copies sold
before it's even released uh just in the
uk alone and more in america and
elsewhere
i think people realize that we've got a
problem man i think people realize that
this
lack of confidence in ourselves this
lack of gratitude for what we have it's
gonna cause real problems and it already
has
and i think some of the divisiveness we
see in society is because we don't feel
like we're pulling in the same direction
and that's why if you think about even
the word debate we talk about well the
importance of debate right but would you
say that what happens on a morning tv
channel that i've been on and i've done
those debates
is that really a debate
is that two people trying to arrive at a
conclusion by testing each other's ideas
not really you know those are two
enemies fighting and trying to win
to me a debate is more like what me you
and anton have around the studio when
we're talking about sometimes quite
difficult subjects and you know you put
an idea forward and i put the opposite
idea forward and anton's got his own
idea and we sit around and we talk and
then eventually we either come to an
understanding or we agree to disagree or
whatever but that's a debate and the
reason that works is we're all pulling
in the same direction
but if we've got to a point as a society
where we feel so disconnected from each
other that our fellow citizens are our
enemy
that we don't want to get to a common
understanding what we want is to destroy
them what we want is to humiliate them
what we want them is for them to lose
that's not a recipe for a healthy
society and most importantly it's not a
recipe for a society that's going to be
able to defend itself or project its
power internationally which is what we
have to do
and obviously social media has been when
it comes to this particular issue you're
more positive follow me on twitter yeah
i mean you're more positive than social
media than social media
than i am i'm a lot more negative about
it
but i mean that's been a disaster for
debate surely
it look the re you say i'm more positive
than you i think i'm just more realistic
than you which is it's not going away
right yeah it's not going away you
hesitate to say yeah to that because
you'd like to smash but see there is no
no there isn't a place you could go with
a hammer and break it all down anymore
no no it's not going to happen right so
we have social media
and it's up to us to learn to use it i
think we will eventually i think there
will be regulations and rules in place
that allow it to be a place that's
healthier
um and i hope that you know depending on
who gets elected that may be more
restrictive or less restrictive and of
course you and i both have tremendous
concerns about the regulation but we
also think some regulation will have to
come in to do course right um social
media hasn't been great in some ways but
on the other hand
look at what we do we we give people an
opportunity to listen to somebody talk
and why i hope that what we do on
trigonometry is facilitating genuine
discussion and we wouldn't be where we
are without social media without all
these technologies so i really think
it's about how we learning to use it
properly
and i think that we will eventually get
to a position where we're able to do
that as a society like i say you will
require the tech companies to modify
things it will require regulation and
require self-restraint too i mean the
way i use social media has changed in
the last couple of years i used to just
love trolling people on it and that
doesn't sound like you mate but actually
if you look at my twitter now i really
don't tend to do that anymore yeah it's
quite rare for me because i'm trying to
be a bit more sensible a bit more
responsible uh with the way that i use
it and i think a lot of people are
feeling that way actually so i think a
lot of the solutions will come from
people themselves taking responsibility
for their actions yeah i do know what
you mean the the part of social media
that i
just makes me deeply uncomfortable and
it's this
knowledge that our brains are being
hacked we're shown the most outrageous
content because that's the thing that's
we're going to engage with because it
stirs our emotions and if you feel angry
about something then you're going to
want to do something about it you're
going to be you know you're going to get
into an argument and you're going to
spend more time on the platform and we
all know how it goes do you not worry
about that of course i do uh all i'm
saying is it's not going away yeah it's
like you know when when the printing
press was invented and all these
publications came out again people who
had
mostly illiterate didn't have a chance
to read anything like that and it caused
you know 150 years of religious war and
conflict uh so that may happen yeah
no
well good to be positive right but you
know what i'm saying is like the only
thing that i can do about that is be
responsible with what i do and advocate
for policies which i think will mitigate
some of those disruptive factors that's
all either of us can do and i'm trying
to do my best and i think you are as
well and we've got a great interview
jaren lanier coming out about that yeah
absolutely and that was a thrill with
the one of the fathers of virtual
reality to talk to him about
you know the way the internet started
the utopian ideals it had him now where
it's ended up it's a brilliant interview
plus a white man with dreadlocks exactly
yeah exactly definitely a vegan oh we
don't know that he might not lives in
california definitely a vegan
but
looking at your book and reading your
book there's an affinity between us in
that
i think it's because the reason we we
see the way the world the way we see it
in particular the west
is because we've seen something else
whereas i think part of the problem is
is that if you're born into this system
well this is just normal yeah you think
it's never going to change you take it
for granted i i absolutely agree with
you and that's why i wrote the book
because i'm trying to give you know i
really you know i think there'll be
people of course who see me as you know
this culture warrior and blah blah blah
blah
but actually i've written the book in a
way that i hope will be really easy for
people who normally might disagree with
me to read because i want them to see
the west through a foreigners eyes and
understand what in russia we have a
saying everything is understood in
comparison
if you think the west and let's say
britain in particular these
racist evil countries the question i
always want to ask is compared to what
this is one of thomas soul's great
questions for dealing with progressive
thinking
compared to what at what cost and i
can't remember the third one now right
but compared to what is a crucial thing
if you're comparing it to some utopia
maybe you could argue the west isn't as
good as it could be but if you're
comparing it to every other human
society that's ever existed we're
actually doing really well
and that's what i wanted to get across
to people i and you know
as you know probably the most
controversial chapter in the book is
about slavery and i make the point in
every interview that i've done that you
know a lot of people are running around
saying oh we talk about it too much and
whatever i actually think and i'm sure
you'll agree with me as a former teacher
we don't teach enough about slavery
but what we do teach is only one tiny
aspect of it which is the transatlantic
slave trade but if you put that in the
broader context of the human experience
most people don't know that human beings
were the first good that was ever traded
right slavery has been with us since the
beginning of time
and the only thing that makes the
western attitude to slavery unique
really i mean there was a few things
that were to do with technology the
ability to transport large numbers of
people across an ocean although the
transit uh saharan slave trade was doing
that across africa not on ships but on
land
but it was really the fact that we ended
it the west end at slavery if when it
was happening in russia when it was
happening in africa when it was
happening in the middle east when it was
happening everywhere the colonial powers
actually spent an awful lot of energy
and money and time ending it and the
trans-saharan slave trade which had a
higher death rate which had more slaves
involved in it it only ended because the
west came in and basically made it stop
right so yes we must understand the
terrible periods in our history when
we've done the wrong thing or did things
that we now regret but it has to be seen
as a part of a bigger context and i
think that's really important to get
across to people which is why i use the
example of my grandfather who was taken
to germany as a slave laborer during
world war ii or my great-grandfather who
was kept in the gulag because he was
useful he was a slave like this isn't
this isn't a simple an issue as dr
scholler screaming about it do you see
what i'm saying yeah and
also as well it doesn't take into
account that there's more slaves than
ever at the moment modern day slavery
right but we don't seem to want to
address that or not many careers to be
built on talking about that that's the
problem yeah
and i think that is part of the problem
but it
one of the things that i've noticed in
the west more and more
and maybe it's just become i've become
more aware of it or it's become more
prevalent i'm not sure which is which
it's just the self flagellation this
constant apologizing which is also it's
not just the fact that people in the
west do it it's if you're western middle
class and white and all of a sudden it
seems for large slaves of these people
they go around apologizing for things
that happen hundreds of years before
they were born doesn't make any sense no
it doesn't but what i think has happened
there is
i talked about this from my first into
john anderson i think it's weaponized
empathy
uh i think people have worked out that
people in the west particularly people
who are comfortable who who grew up with
genuine advantages in life like money
and opportunity to go to a good school
and two parents and all of these things
they feel guilty uh they've been made to
feel guilty because probably they don't
have many that many struggles in their
life on the sort of historical
perspective scale
and so they they need something to to to
sort of invest themselves emotionally
into
and there are some people who've worked
that out these activists have worked
that out and they're pushing this agenda
knowing that it's gonna they're gonna
persuade people and that's why you've
got gary lineker who clearly doesn't
know a thing about a thing doesn't know
anything about anything except football
uh banging on about this stuff
constantly and because he gets the likes
and the dopamine hits and whatever right
that's why it's happening because it's
weaponized empathy and then it's
rewarded
if you go around self-flagellating
people are going to pat you on the back
and say oh well done right whereas if
you say actually i'm not responsible for
something that people did 300 years ago
you're automatically a bigger you're
racist and all this other stuff so
that's disincentivized but if you think
about if you just pause for a second
just take stock of what we're talking
about
i use this in the book even in the torah
the one of the oldest scriptures which
is no by no means progressive let me
tell you i'm sure it's got a few
problematic passages yeah it's probably
a bit transphobic it talks about how
children must not be punished for the
sins of their fathers and fathers must
not be punished for the sins of their
children
we we have gone backwards so far
we are now in pre
prehistoric times in terms of our
attitudes to things we're literally
trying to hold people accountable for
something relatives of theirs did
that they never even met and in most
cases they aren't even relatives francis
they are people who just happen to have
the same skin color
not even by the way the same ethnicity
like you right
you are descended from irish and
venezuelan people right
i don't think you your ancestors would
have been that heavily involved in the
slave trade yet someone would look at
you and go well you're responsible you
need to apologize and you need to pay
reparations
it this is a ass backward idea
that is millenni people millennia like
when they were just herding sheep they
knew this was wrong and we're doing now
in the modern world
it seems to me that
and it's one of the things that we're
doing in
in one of the things that you talked
about in your book that you put it more
eloquently than me it seems like we've
got the west is this
block of jenga you know the game jenga
yeah and we just seem to be pulling out
pieces randomly without even considering
why the piece is there or actually what
it's upholding that's a great metaphor
and that's exactly how i feel that
you've put mate i don't need i didn't
need the book just that that
was good but that's it that's it and you
know one of the things i talk about
right as you know at the very very very
end it's literally the last passage of
the book
is
uh my grandmother who was born in a
concentration in gulag um
and when her parents were eventually
released
anyone who was a prisoner in the gulag
was not allowed to live in the major
cities of the soviet union uh they they
had to live in the periphery in the
small towns far away from the center
and the only people that lived in these
remote towns were people who'd been in
the gulags as prisoners people who'd
been in the gulags as camp guards and
the local native population who were
very small so basically you had let's
say a town of 10 000 people and most of
the people there would have been former
prisoners in the gulag and a lot of the
other people were guards in the gulag
right
and
my grandmother's family lived in the
same landing
as a family who where the man had been a
god in one of these camps
and when stalin died
there was a big revelation that the the
khrushchev exposed the cult of
personality they condemned all the
atrocities and the excesses they said it
was not the party wishes it was stalin
himself or whatever and they basically
apologized and exposed what had been
happening
and
a lot of these men in who had been
guards in the camps they ended up
shooting themselves
because they so believed in this
ideology they so believed that they they
they can demonize people that they
disagree with that oh they must be in
the camp for a good reason right we are
we're justified to condemn these people
we're justified to treat them like
they're second-class citizens to talk
down to them to call them names to bully
them we're justified in all of this
because we have the right ideology
and
this is kind of my invitation to people
who are maybe not naturally aligned with
some of the stuff that you and i talk
about is
don't be one of those people
don't be one of these useful idiots who
goes along with treating people badly
because you believe you have the right
ideology
you're not a good person if you're
sending jk rowling death threats
you're not you're not a good person if
you're demonizing people who voted in a
referendum in a different way to you
you're not doing good
you're not helping you're making things
worse
and likewise by the way on the right
it's the same you know
every time
you genuinely attack people or or
dehumanize people who are of a different
point of view to you
you're not helping now you and i will
joke and we're comedians and we will
satirize and mock and whatever and
that's all fine you know but i think
that there's lines that we don't want to
cross in in the in the name of ideology
and it worries me that here in the west
we're doing that a lot and the example i
give you know um
the americans obviously were the first
to develop a nuclear bomb
and the soviets were nowhere near do you
know how they got one
no there were two um
particularly uh there were two very big
names i i think klaus fox is one of his
names and there was another one
two people who were involved in the
manhattan project in the united states
who were sympathetic to the communist
cause and they basically gave
stalin
the soviet union the nuclear bomb
because they were ideologically
supportive of the regime
that's what that's what ideology will do
to people that's why one of the opening
bits of the book is i talk about how
living in the soviet union taught me
never to buy into someone else's
ideology because it will make you always
always make you violate your own
principles
and make you do bad things this is
actually what i found interesting about
douglas murray's review in the telegraph
which he was very generous with he
quoted that line because i think that's
true and that's why you know when we
talk about the direction of the show
we've we never wanted to be on the right
or on the left we're trying to explore
each issue on its merits and not be
ideological because ideology will always
blind you whatever that ideology is
whether it's progressivism or
conservatism or liberalism or
libertarianism or feminism or whatever
area
you have where you're looking at things
ideologically instead of on the basis of
the facts you're going to find yourself
doing things you don't agree with later
in life and that's why i try and stay
away from it and it's also as well it
strikes me
it's all people who follow a particular
ideology
when you're
you're so certain about something
100
certain
it's a dangerous place to be you should
always have room for doubt you should
always have room for doubt because we're
all fallible we're all human we're all
flawed none of us is perfect none of us
is all seeing none of us is all knowing
and that's a problem for me with a lot
of the ideology that you
is that phrase you we're on the right
side of history and my own responses how
do you know yeah
how do you know how do you know about
people 200 years are going to view you
you know if you look at the way we look
at people 200 years ago it's not
favorable so what makes you think you're
any better
i agree i agree i and i think
that's why you've always got to be
careful uh because this is why i think
it's really important to constantly be
checking with yourself about your
actions and it's i'm not saying my
actions always perfect by the way and
but i am constantly doing this and going
are my actions
the actions of a person that i i like
and respect
because it doesn't matter what your
ideology is you can believe in in
progress and equality and all of this
stuff but as you and i know from the
comedy industry there are lots of people
who believe that and and bang on about
it while groping women in the green room
right um and it's the same with almost
anything it's like if like i say if
you're if you're a hateful person i
don't care what your ideology is i don't
care how accurate it is you're a hateful
person right and that's my worry with
ideology that's how you can excuse
yourself for being a nasty person or a
hateful person or a person that attacks
people or as in the case of our former
guest james cavarini you know he he has
a fundraiser with jk rowling and people
now smashing in windows in in his
restaurant
or writing one-star reviews or whatever
you know
you've got to check in with yourself and
go this isn't right why am i doing this
why am i attacking people why am i
trying to smear people why am i
destroying people's careers now as i say
again you and i mock people that we
disagree with we mock stupid ideas and
we will always continue to do that but
i'd like to think we've never gone after
anyone's career we've never tried to
destroy their livelihood or anything
like that
because i think that's really when you
know that you've got to the wrong place
and and part of the problem as well with
this ideology in all ideologies
is that it's a really easy way for
people
to mask who they truly are
where they go oh i'm this progressive
liberal and it's a fantastic cloak
for this behavior that is
despicable and violent wrong and we've
seen it time after time but we joke
about it in our own industry in comedy
formerly a former industry in comedy we
always said it's always awoke as
comedians that the biggest perverts
because what a fantastic way yeah to
cloak yourself
then by pretending to be virtuous yeah
exactly and
so that's why i think it's really
important not to buy into any ideology
and to think to think those things
through
but i also think you know i wanted to
write the book because i want to lay
these issues to rest
so like we said at the very beginning we
can focus on the things that matter i
think that's really important and that's
one of the reasons you know we talk
about certain issues that
that
people would consider progressive but
not as much as we used to because i i
think we'll continue obviously to call
out things that are wrong on both right
and left but as i say i think we've got
a lot of bigger fish to fry at the
moment in society and we've got to focus
on that and i think people are waking up
to that slowly but surely you know it's
all very well screaming at twitter that
somebody has missed you know not used
the correct pronoun etc but if you can't
afford to fill your car up
does it really matter exactly
so that being the case
looking back at the soviet union and
living in that
what was it like growing up
in that country in that system
well this is one of the reasons that i
think the book is so relevant now i mean
my grandfather uh so i've mentioned
about five grandfathers at this point
and they're all different ones my
grandfather who lived in the uk who
moved to the uk the reason he ended up
in the uk is that he criticized the
soviet invasion of afghanistan
and when he did this he was made
unemployable ostracized by many of his
friends yeah
and eventually was forced to leave the
country and find a new job how
unfamiliar is that
to the 21st century western countries
someone expressing the wrong opinion
being made unemployable and ostracized
by their their friendship circle
not that unfamiliar right so i'm afraid
we're we are adopting some of the worst
elements of that society
and
there will be other parallels when
people read the book and and
read about some of the things that used
to happen i think it will open their
eyes because to most people they think
that
what's happening in the west now is new
and unprecedented and blah blah blah
blah blah but it's really not
even if you look at you know i know many
of our audience will know this because
i've talked about this before but for
those who don't
political correctness
isn't something that happened in the
1990s and pissed off richard littlejohn
and
and kelvin mckenzie and other tabloid
editors
political correctness comes from the
soviet union i i have a whole chapter in
the book about
uh speech and how it's being misused now
and and the way that words are being
changed and political correctness was a
way of preventing people from expressing
an opinion that was counted to the party
line
does that sound unfamiliar
not really so this is my point we are
adopting some of the worst elements of
the very societies that we spent decades
trying to defeat
but it wasn't
like all societies there was a lot of
negatives with the soviet union but
there was also some positives absolutely
well i again i talk about there's a
whole chapter in the book out about this
and it was it was my first ever article
that i wrote uh it was called growing up
in a progressive utopia it was on
coilette and i talk about the wealth how
little wealth inequality there was the
fact that there was universal health
care education was free and in fact
university students were paid to study
and all of this stuff but the cost of it
in my opinion wasn't worth it and and i
detail the cost of it in the book yeah
and the the little things that i just
found fascinating where
if you know what you didn't have a
choice about what your career was no no
no you you went to to to university you
may get a choice as to what to study
and then from there on you were assigned
the job
and you would go wherever you were sent
and that was it and what and what
happened if you went well actually you
know what i don't want to be a
biochemist i always really wanted to be
a school teacher
uh yeah i i look at different stages it
would have been different it would have
been dependent on the bribes you could
pay and the connections you had it was
all sort of based on that but generally
speaking you would get a job assigned to
you and you would go and do that job do
you know the one one of the things that
i found so interesting is when you
talked to me about
service culture in the soviet union and
how the way and how
in for in ex-soviet countries the
service is always atrocious let's talk
about that a little bit well this is how
you know a chinese restaurant is
actually authentic as if you get shared
service oh absolutely yeah uh in the
soviet union uh the reason that even now
when you go to that part of the world
the service might not be great in some
places it's changing now because the
people who who are like that are sort of
dying out or at least not working in
restaurants it's usually younger people
but the reason it was unfriendly and
hostile was that
the waiter was the one who had the power
because they could give you
a plate of food that had a lot of meat
on it or not much meat on it and you
couldn't really do anything about it so
they were the ones that were in charge
it was the same with people who would
sell something to you in a shop they
could afford they could get bribes of
people
to get the right goods and stuff like
that because everything was scarce and
therefore they had the power over the
distribution of it
so in many ways it just incentivized
corruption of course it did yeah of
course it did which is one of the
reasons russia remains so corrupt today
and in all post-soviet countries really
particularly
other than the baltics where the problem
is is lesson because they were never
really fully part of the soviet union
that long
you know and the last time we were here
we were talking about
putin and we were talking about the
invasion
and you saw that coming
why well especially what was it was it
the background was it
seeing the way the west was going what
was it that made you all that gave you
that particular insight well
after 2014 it was clear that putin was
going to carry on with what he was doing
because there was no push back from the
west
i think after 2020
and biden's election it was clear that
this was going to be an opportunity and
i think also like i said seeing how
divided
the western society was i actually think
in some ways putin perhaps made the same
miscalculation that i made which is i
overestimated how
divided we are i thought we're more
divided and the response would be less
strong
the response has actually been quite
unified other than germany from western
countries so i think it was those three
things really the the fact that the
united states was taking its eye off the
ball with all of the election stuff that
was happening there the fact that the
west was being perceived with russian
help by the way of being very divided
and unwilling to assert itself and the
fact that putin already took a piece of
ukraine in 2014 and there wasn't really
much pushback
so going back and focusing on the things
that are happening and this and the
issues that we're talking about the big
issue is of course and we've touched on
it before
what is a woman and what we saw and what
we've seen recently is this alliance
between conservatives and gender
critical feminists yeah that was never
going to last
no no absolutely not and
it's starting to break apart or
certainly throw at the edges no i think
it is breaking apart yeah you see now jk
rowling having spats with matt walsh and
all of this
of course it's breaking but i think one
of the reasons actually is that i think
the gender critical feminists feel that
they're winning
you know you've got the maya four
starter the kiera bell the you know
you've got candidates now who are
talking about this for running for
leadership of the tory party you're
seeing other changes happening uh and i
think they sort of think they don't need
the conservatives anymore and that's
maybe one of the reasons that they're
willing to be a bit more confrontational
about it but the other thing is very
interesting we obviously just recorded
an interview with louise perry who i was
very impressed by who is a feminist
who's written a book called the case
against the sexual revolution and one of
the things that you probably noticed
that we would she was sort of talking
about chivalry and you know not actual
equality and stuff like that and i think
you know this is probably going to annoy
some people including in our audience
but it doesn't need to be said like
the problem with feminism is feminists
never wanted equality
they talked about it but it's not what
they wanted and i don't blame them for
it by the way i don't think equality in
that very narrow sense is necessarily
what the right solution is but it was
like
i mean i'll prove it to you no feminist
wants equality because think about this
right if you you and i are friends and
we like each other but let's imagine
that we didn't and i you came over here
and spat in my face yeah right the
chances are i would hit you
that is the code between men we all know
it we all approve of it is fine it's the
way it's always worked blah blah blah
blah blah right there's not a feminist
in the world who says that if you were a
woman and you gave her came over here
and spat in my face i should punch you
there's no one who's going to defend
that if a feminist has asked about that
they'll say well male violence blah blah
blah blah blah and you know and
basically they want you and me to become
a little bit more like them
right
and what the smart feminists are
starting to realize actually the sexual
revolution has been really bad for both
sexes but especially for women
especially for women and i think that's
part of the other reason that this
alliance is fraying or breaking apart
because now that i think the gender
critical feminists feel like they're
making progress they're like oh [ __ ]
these guys that we've been aligned with
they're not on our team which they're
not
by the way they're absolutely not
and also
they're starting to realize that
equality wasn't really all it was made
out to be no you know and that's
probably going to be the next
conversation that we'll have as a
society because i've always
you know the feminism is a weird word
because it means
all things to all women right there's
about 53 different ways of doing
feminism some of which i really agree
with and i think are great and some of
which i think are damaging and
destructive and quite pointless and just
people who angry at the dead um
and
we're going to have to work out a path
through that
as a society because driving men and
women apart which some feminists have
tried to do
i'm not sure that's a good outcome for
society either so as i say the smart
feminists are starting to realize that
actually we're going to have to change
the conversation a little bit and i
think that will be one of the next
things that we
talk about on the show in a big way i
suspect yeah and it's also the role of
the family you sometimes wonder that you
see
all these people having these pointless
conversations on twitter
no one's really having kids anymore and
you think well i am yeah you are maybe
when are you going to get started let's
get pumping in here i don't know
when anton and i get a surrogate but
anyway
mate you've we've talked with louise
perry about how bad that is yeah how
immoral and unethical that is and i
agree with it by the way it is
absolutely it is but
you do think would people be having
these pointless conversations if they
had a family right
if they were able to settle down if
things weren't the way they were now
look you know you can always say you
know you can blame a variety of external
factors and ultimately your life is in
your hands yes i agree with that but the
reality is it's becoming more and more
difficult for people to start a family
yeah and it's creating a wealth of
problems
that we're seeing right the way through
society that's why i have a whole
chapter in the book about the housing
crisis yeah it's not just a book about
how the woke our idiots because i don't
think there's any value in that i'm
trying to talk about how we get to a
better society and fixing the housing
crisis is going to be one of the main
ways of doing that in this country it's
essential and this is what really pisses
me off about michael gove is when he
talks about woke people and i'm not
you're a housing minister mate
you want people to be conservative yet
you're not incentivizing them to have to
be conservative because they've got
nothing to conserve they've got no
assets so you can shut your mouth not
that i am a big fan of michael gove but
i think the problem extends slightly
beyond him and we've seen you know we've
we're not doing what we need to be doing
for decades on that issue now but he's
done very little to resolve it
admittedly uh like everybody else yeah
but and and so the point is it's that
i think what we talk about a lot on the
show and what you talked about in your
book is you know going back to that
metaphor or you know of jengar of
pulling things apart
but isn't the problem that there's these
people there's a lot of people of our
generation and younger who feel they've
got nothing invested in society yeah i
think that's true uh i do also think as
you know you know i've always been
someone who was very interested in
personal development and making the most
of my life and
growing as a person i do think the
circumstances are more difficult than
they've been in the past and i also
think they're going to get even more
difficult but i also think that's a
reason for people of our generation and
younger to work harder to be more
creative to be smarter
you know we can all sit here and
complain about the state of the world if
i know one thing if there's one thing i
know is if you want your life to be
better you're gonna have to do something
about it
and that's the great thing about the
west isn't it really that's the thing
about the west is almost everywhere else
you have to have family connections blah
blah blah blah blah in the west if
you're smart if you're talented if
you're driven if you're creative you
will make it and that's always my
message to people
especially young people young people do
not hear that enough man i didn't hear
as a young person enough
you live in a society in which you can
make it you can make something of
yourself
and that's one of the reasons that you
know i'm
i love living in britain as you know but
i am also very
uh
inspired by some of the american ways of
thinking as well because that go-getter
attitude to me is inspiring i think it's
really important uh and i've tried to
have that as part of our ethos here on
the show you know we've made a lot of
ourselves from a very low start i think
it's fair to say and i think partly is
that you and i both have an anton as
well have that attitude like we want to
get better we want to make the show as
good as it possible i want to write a
book you're going on a stand up so we're
doing live shows like we want to do
stuff
we want to create stuff and i that's
always the message i have for young
people you know we talk about in sales
and all these people like
no one's going to give it to you man you
got to go out and you've got to work for
it and that's so i hear you on the
housing crisis i know it's a big problem
i have a whole chapter in the book but
also
everybody's just you're going to have to
step up if you want something yeah you
just are and this is a problem is that
we've been incentivized to play victim
yeah
and i am saying in the book it's not
good for you don't be a victim you're
not a victim
everyone's a victim and no one's a
victim
it's not helpful especially if you're a
victim to think of yourself as a victim
it's really not going to make your life
better it's just going to make it worse
so instead of that focus on the
positives what can you do what can you
create what can you make that's of value
to other people if you do that in this
society unlike most others you will
succeed
and i think that is a great point to
pause it and what we're going to do
is we're going to collect your super
chats your paypal send them through and
then i will look through them during the
break with my glamorous assistant anton
and we are going to put your questions
to constantin so send through your
paypals
send through your super chats and during
this very short uh commercial break
makes the sound
sound professional doesn't it we're
gonna collate them and we're gonna put
them to constantine thank you so much
for watching guys we'll be back after
these very short adverts see you soon
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
i'm from russia i cannot love anything
apart from vodka miserable literature
and a horrendous downfall of my people
but yes i find trigonometry satisfactory
and do you like live shows of course but
only if it's check of play about
collapse of russian aristocracy as they
face death and obscurity before the
glorious might of the proletariat and
the beautiful revolution
okay mate well if you like trigonometry
live shows then get your credit card out
for the lads because we're coming to the
edinburgh festival this august we have
only booked two shows august 6th and 7th
because if we do more the comedy
industry will treat us like the tsars
and execute us that's right we're going
to be in edinburgh for two days only
saturday's guest is andrew doyle which
is sure to sell out our other guest is
leo curse which means when nicola
sturgeon hears about it she'll ban us
from scotland herself tickets are sure
to sell out and when they're gone
they're gone click on the link below and
we'll see you in edinburgh on the 6th
and 7th of august at the gilded balloon
teviet come and see us before hordes of
left-wing comedians try to put us in
gulag
we hope you're enjoying this incredible
interview
did you know that you can ask guests
your questions that's right when you
join our locals community not only will
you know who we're about to interview
you have the opportunity to ask them
your questions you have the chance to
ask jordan peterson the co-founder of
extinction rebellion nigel farage
douglas murray andrew doyle jeff norcott
simon evans larry elder david bedeal
andrew sullivan megan kelly julia
hartley brewer lord nigel lawson brett
weinstein
inaudible david nutt jimmy dore gad sad
blair white melissa chen trevor phillips
ayanne hersey ali glenn lowry bridgefed
i see jim rickards carl benjamin and so
many more plus we're about to interview
some of the biggest guests in the world
we can't name them just yet but trust me
they're huge metaphorically speaking not
just because they're american our locals
gives you access to a great community of
like-minded people where you can share
memes and make new and problematic
friends you also get early access to
live shows and we're about to release
details of our tour so you'll want to
know about that as well
on the higher tiers you get monthly
supporter calls and the opportunity to
have a meal or a call with us click the
link below or go to
trigonometry.locals.com
and join the community that's
trigonometry.locals.com
we'll see you there
hello guys and welcome back remember
that you've still got a chance to send
your super chat and your paypal's
through and you'll be able to ask
constantin dirk questions directly i'll
first we want them to buy the book by
the way oh yes and you want that is a
good point is it yeah it is a good point
so if you but you can also buy the book
and the links are in the description so
buy yourself a copy also available on
amazon and kindle and as an audio book
as well francis i would say like
obviously i really appreciate everyone's
already put the book and people sending
super chats and all that the one thing i
would ask is if you do plan to get the
book
get it now because any sale between now
and saturday gets registered for the
sunday times bestseller list and i think
i'm very close to being on it if not
already on it but it's close so uh all
the sales that happen in this week are
like really really important and so if
you're planning to get the book or
you're planning to get it for a friend
or a family member like now would be a
great time from my perspective but you
know i appreciate everyone that's
supporting us already absolutely so get
the book next month guys now now get it
as soon as he can so but thank you
everybody for watching
we've got our first question it's from
emmy baker lana
and she said vbl what's
yeah absolutely so so do we all she says
hi constantin now you and your wife have
become parents how will you keep your
love letter relevant to him seeing that
he's been born here and won't have had
the experience you've both had in your
own lives
well one of the things that i'm very
keen on is that he spends a lot of time
with our both both our families
in eastern europe my family in armenia
and sees a different world i know that
for example you were born in this
country but it was your experience of
being in venezuela and seeing that
country that sort of helped you
understand the broader context so i hope
i'm hopeful that
i doubt nikolai's children will will
have that perspective but my children i
think will yeah
great uh first first answer uh the
elena stansbee asks uh what part of your
book am i gonna cry at first
hmm
i actually think the preface
really yeah
i cry when i read the preface
there you go because i put a lot of a
lot of my a lot of
my
biggest fears into it i suppose and also
you know i wrote it in a way that i
think
is is kind of quite
um
emotional you know um
and yeah like i say it's
it's kind of i hope it's not prophetic
but if it is then we're all in for a
rough time
okay
zoe solanki asks when writing the book
did it help you come to any new
conclusions that you weren't aware of
before you know one of the things that
writing the book was really helpful is
because i had the focus that i wanted
i wanted like a random person on the
street to be able to pick it up i didn't
want it to be some sort of like culture
warrior treatise you know what i mean so
i wanted it to be able to be read by
people who had a different point of view
to me rather than just you know throwing
red meat to the base if you like
uh it forced me to really examine my
arguments and to make sure that they
that i was making a good argument
instead of just making fun of stupid
people who are on the other side of me
you know what i mean because that's very
easy yeah i really wanted to make what i
thought was a good and persuasive
argument that would win over somebody
who was a neutral
excellent answer uh our next question is
from mr winter oh great he says looks
like he's got his big boy pants on today
despite the fact that your pamphlet will
fill poundland faster than your headline
is receding
and despite my book published when i'm
25 is better you've done well
so that was the first part but then he
wrote a second part to it where he says
bigotry aside well done my friend i wish
you all the success decay and west can
provide
my question is
can we stop the tide we stand against i
think we can i really do think we can
and
that's why if i didn't think we could i
wouldn't bother writing the book to be
honest i wrote the book because i think
we can i actually feel that the pendulum
is slowing i don't know if it's swinging
back yet
and i have to say you know as much as
i'm concerned about making sure the
pendulum slows and stops i do worry
about the overswing because for every
revolution the counter revolution is
just as ugly
so
i suspect it's quite likely that five or
ten years from now you and i are sitting
here talking about the evil right
wingers who've gone too far which at
least will be a more natural place for
us to be yeah exactly because back to
our roots yeah because you're jewish and
i look jewish so exactly but you know
what i mean like i i'm concerned we've
got to make sure that in opposing some
of the craziness of the left we don't
become crazy ourselves that's i think
that's really important absolutely
richard the horse uh and what a great
question from a horse says uh was one
thing from another culture that you
think the the west could learn from or
should implement
oh there's no question and you saw it
when you came to armenia it's family
large families connected through
generations
cousins and brothers and sisters who
truly love each other and spend lots of
time together
we are becoming very atomized in the
west and i think ricky bexsan made this
point we talked about how actually a lot
of the ethnic minority communities in
the uk do have that cohesion and family
connection that we are losing
and i think that's really really
important and i know that's it's
you know one of the most meaningful
things in my life like i love my life
right the way i love what we do here i
love the friendships that we've built
with you and with anton and with other
people uh you know i'm i'm loving
everything i loved writing the book i
love the fact that
it's not even out yet and thousands of
people have kindly bought it and i'm
going to read it like it's incredible my
life
you know my wife and i have just had a
baby
he's wonder like i love everything but
the fact that i live far from my family
is the one thing that
you know it's difficult it's genuinely
difficult and if there was one thing i
could change about my life without
losing all the good stuff it would be
that and i do think that far too many
people particularly as families get
smaller as we move after we
you know leave school or whatever
we're becoming very disconnected the
number of people who end up in a in a in
a in a home when they're elderly
troubles me very much
it's not how we should treat our family
it's not how we should treat our parents
i'm not judging anyone you know for the
individual circumstances i'm just saying
at the level of society the disconnect
between different generations
is not good man and if there's one thing
that we could pick up from more
traditional cultures it's it's the
preserving the family it's preserving
the big family of over generations and
over time
um that's to me that's really really
important now of course you know i feel
like what we have here is kind of a
family but it's not the same no you know
it's not the same uh
so yeah i think that's really important
and the other thing you know what it is
muslims are right about gambling
horrible fish awful awful vice no joke
generally is amy vows uh who
lovely lovely supporter of the show she
asked was there a specific moment when
you realize you love the anglo-sphere
and do you have a favorite historical
anglo figure that you look up to
um that's a good question
favorite historical figure
i don't know what i would say is i am
really really interested in the history
of the american revolution
um because this was a time when people
came together and then they were forced
to conceive a new society almost from
scratch in very very unusual i would say
unique circumstances really and because
of that they were forced to think about
the way a society should be organized in
a way that we in europe really don't
we're sort of like oh yeah you know
everything's worked out we don't really
have to have these conversations we can
just sort of argue about the tax rate
and and you know what a woman is and
whatever and that's it
uh so i'm really interested in that
period and there were a lot of figures
who contributed a lot to the way we now
think about things that came that come
out of that period um
but in terms of uh when i realized that
i was very
i mean love love is of course in the
title but i really think of it more as
gratitude
you know and i sort of feel that every
day since since i became an adult and
was present to the difference between
what we have here and what we have
elsewhere you know and and i tried to
you know we talked about it with richard
graham and i think it was that we every
time we have a meal here we say grace
even though none of us is religious
because it just connects with that
gratitude that i think is really
important to have particularly if you're
as fortunate and as genuinely privileged
as we all are
so uh
cass8228 with a very generous super chat
thank you very much cass and you said
francis the jenga you were talking about
is called deconstruction it is a marxist
tactic
in brackets post-modernist that is meant
to tear apart society hence her name it
is meant to deconstruct society so a
marxist equity regime can be installed
he's got no question i think he's just
making a point
the man paid a hundred dollars let him
make his point yeah exactly so that is
the point uh
meaning the the head of emptiness or
empty head whichever way you want to
interpret it says if the west were to
write you a letter back
what do you think it would say
and the second question is what if it
was written by mr winter
it would say something about pretty
patel yeah on the second one i don't
know you know
i might sound cheesy to some people but
i i genuinely feel very grateful to be
here as i think you know
uh and i would just hope that if the
west were to write a letter back to me
he would it would also appreciate that
i've tried to make the best of my time
here and contribute to the society and i
feel that even doing the show not to
forget about it going on youtube just in
terms of the fact that you and i have
created something here that employs
like you know
probably the best part of a dozen people
at this point right that that have a
meaningful job that they love and enjoy
contributing to
that to me you know that that's enough
you know i hope that i i'm contributing
and i hope that you know i was very
touched when douglas said that he
uh you know i am i express gratitude to
the west and my appreciation for it and
he said we're lucky to have him like
that to me means a lot yeah absolutely
kieran joseph says wondering if ff could
oh fff no if kk could sign a copy in
edinburgh i'll sign it as well mate yeah
two for one news yeah uh yeah if you
come to the live show i'll i'll come
outside and definitely sign up for you
perfect kieran so there we go uh we're
gonna look through um we've got paypal
as well we do have paypal uh jillian
colucci with a very italian day but this
is not a raw but we will do the eggs and
then anyway yeah exactly it says i
increasingly encounter people lacking
the skills to form an argument uh what
modification can be made in social media
space spaces to help rebuild these
skills and get back to proper human
discourse mate i don't think it's about
social media i think it's about
education
if you're not taught to think as a at an
early age and think through arguments i
mean would you agree with this as a
former teacher yeah we're not taught how
to argue we're not we're not i i
actually we started to introduce it at
school at school like we did as a group
of teachers in the last year of primary
school and we taught our children to
have discussions to you know to
represent one side to represent another
side and to listen but i don't think
that goes on in a lot of schools
well one place that you would have
noticed it going on a lot
is when you came with me to armenia yeah
my family yeah
this is so much of where this all comes
from and it's about parenting yeah
in my family there was a culture of
discussing ideas and debating things and
things sometimes getting heated but no
one crossing lines no it was just a
conversation which is what you and i
often do anton and
all of us right
you have to educate children from a
young age how to have these discussions
if you don't you can't then be upset
that they're not doing it although i
completely agree with you so uh we've
cracked through a lot of them a lot of
the old super chats so we have got one
from francois grief friends with grief
he's from city africa he says i'm not
going to do the rest of it in an
accident we'll save that for raw
legal immigrants to western countries
are almost always over achievers musk is
the best example yet legal immigrants
must jump through hoops to get to into
america britain oz etc liberals on the
other hand and as a general rule want to
give illegal immigrants an easy entrance
why do you think
that is and he says
and it says by the way it feels weird
not being allowed to troll two top
comedians
uh well
i think we've got to be careful i i
don't think it's true that you know
everyone on on the sort of liberal left
wants to make it easy for for illegal
immigrants to come here but the reason
that those of them that do
is
look
the right and left both have problems
and they're different in nature the
right is sometimes too cold and clinical
and analytical and lacks compassion
where sometimes necessary the left's
problem which is to franco's point is
they have too much heart and not enough
head and so they're well well i want
everyone to have what we have and uh
which which is understandable
right
but they're not thinking about the
practical consequences i think that's
where they're coming from and by the way
i
i'm in favor of
allowing a certain small number of
refugees who are properly vetted to come
to this country but i think illegal
immigration is an abomination it
shouldn't be happening
the fact that you've got people getting
into boats and going over the it just
shouldn't be happening they're jumping
the line they're breaking the laws of
this country we don't know who they are
we haven't made sure look francis i'm a
democrat if the people of britain vote
to have an open border i mean i think
that's an idiotic idea but they're
entitled to do that and if the people of
britain vote for restrictive immigration
policy they're entitled to do that as
well and the problem we have now is that
the policy that was
that the politicians keep talking about
and running on when they stand for
parliament and they stand to be prime
minister is not what we're getting
and i think that's a big problem it's a
big problem that's storing up a lot of
resentment for later oh absolutely
because
it puts a pressure on everything it puts
pressure on housing it puts the pressure
on public services no but my point is
something else which is forget about all
that it's whatever your view of on
immigration is
we're not getting what the people voted
for of course
that's to me the biggest problem and
then of course the other stuff you know
it's a separate issue
so this is from karen and she asked do
you think all the trivial social justice
warrior shouting and bullying is being
used to distract us from the real
problems in the world that really matter
you know keep the privilege in the west
dumb and numb and therefore control the
masses and take our freedoms away well i
think i don't know whether there is like
a global conspiracy to make that happen
but that is definitely the consequence
for sure that is absolutely what's
happening karen we are distracted we are
divided and uh you know we're missing
some important things that are going on
in the world right now we are we're
missing lots and lots of important
things so we've just got another one
sent through so here we go there was
about five or six minutes yeah we've
cracked through a lot of them and some
of them there was there was just trolls
from bloody skies guys yeah and and a
few others yeah ban him bannon burnham
so this is from liam poulos or pools he
says do you think you foreigned up his
name yeah polish hey liam poole is
do you think there is a correlation
between increasing multiculturalism and
increasing polarization in a country can
the american constitution cater for more
for modern radical ideas
well two separate questions i don't want
to comment about the american
constitution because it's very much out
of my wheelhouse but in terms of
multiculturalism
i always try to make this and this is a
really important distinction for us is
between a multi-ethnic society a society
in which there are many people of
different ethnicities and a
multicultural society a culture a
society in which people are encouraged
to retain the culture which they brought
with them from a foreign country
and a multi-ethnic society can work
absolutely fine
as long as people have an overarching
common identity that they can all unite
behind for example we say we're all
british we're all american but the
moment you start making society
multicultural that is to say well look
if you've come here from russia you
don't need to become british you don't
need to teach learn the language you
don't need to integrate no you you live
with other russians in a small ghetto
eat russian food speak russian don't
learn the local language et cetera et
cetera et cetera that's a problem and we
have pockets in this country as we
talked with at hussein about yeah where
there are certain communities that have
integrated incredibly well and there are
certain other communities often coming
from the same geographical area
who've become a world unto themselves
who are insulated who have their backs
turned upon the rest of society who who
practice different customs who want
their own legal system
we can't have that that is a recipe for
disaster completely agree uh
sven heliga
uh
there's people who are watching this who
don't watch rawhid just like why are
they doing that uh he and he asked i
still get blank stairs when i use the
term the west
do you think we'll be able to bring it
back fully into common usage
i think so i i haven't encountered that
problem particularly but uh as if you
were here at the beginning and i made
the point that of course the book is
called an immigrant's love letter to the
west but i was really talking
specifically about the anglo-sphere
because i think it's it's different in
the way that it does things to even the
rest of the west we don't want to
associate with the french and the
germans oh absolutely not mate and
according uh to our guests today peter
zahan
it's not looking good for the germans
you're going to have to watch that
episode it is absolutely brilliant uh
bloody skies guys oh what was wrong with
my question uh he says there was no
reference to peggy to pegging and what
anything else was uh
i just can't say it bloody skies uh so
uh let's see what we have got left i
think that has got anton is that it
everything i think that's pretty much i
think that's pretty much everything
we have run out of
time
guys thank you so much for joining in
our plan is that we're going to be doing
a lot more of these uh we're going to be
constantly i'm going to write a book a
month guys yeah exactly we're going to
be doing a lot more talking about
the state of the world as we see it the
challenges that we are all going to face
thank you so much for tuning in to this
very special episode our episodes
normally go out on wednesday or
something so that's great do we want
them to buy the book though yes i am
going to get to that in a second well
maybe they've all switched off by now
tell them to buy the [ __ ] book buy
the book the link is in the comments it
is a great read an immigrant's a love
letter to the west
it's a brilliant brilliant book i have
read it we have all read it we urge you
to buy it dougie is a
dougie loved it douglas murray he
absolutely loved it and the sunday times
and the sunday times and peter pagosian
and peter bergossian
and my mum and your mum and your dad
actually neither of them particularly
read it or liked it
but yes so make sure to buy it thank you
so much for watching us episodes always
go out wednesday and sunday 7 p.m uk
time
it's also available as a podcast thank
you for contributing thank you for
watching and thank you for listening
take care and we'll see you soon